- Upbeat Music
- [Narrator] We as a teaching staff,
we're going to learn best
when we learn from each other.
- It was there, they just
don't trust themselves
- [Narrator] Because we participate
in small groups called flocks,
we have this profound sense that
we're not alone in this work.
- Upbeat music
- At Pearlcone, we have
a really clear structure,
because when you're
consistent room to room,
hallway to hallway, academy to academy,
kids know what to expect,
and so they feel safe
within that structure,
and are quicker to learn.
- I feel like we've built a culture of
you know what the expectation is.
- [Jessica] The flock was developed
by a group of teachers
born out of the idea
that we want consistency across the board,
also the level and rigor of instruction.
- Part of the goal is teamwork
and making sure that
everyone participates, right?
- [Narrator] We are really
clear about our expectations,
so we have five core values.
They are in every hallway
and in every classroom.
So they see it all the time,
and they hear it all the time.
We also have non-negotiables
that are really specific.
We always look for; are we
promoting the core values
within our classrooms and
are we holding kid to
behavioral expectations
called the non-negotiables.
So the flock was born out of trying to
gain a consistency classroom to classroom
with those expectations for kids.
- Alright you guys know
what's expected of you today,
correct?
- Yes.
- We took a model of
looking at peer feedback
and how we could really support each other
for the sake of our
kids we have teachers of
various disciplines and
various years of experience.
We're looking at classroom
behavior, classroom culture.
Looking at those core values
we can kind of check off
what's being adhered to, or broken.
The rubric is both
qualitative and quantitative.
So you're able to write
notes on what you see and
writing that evidence down
to have more meaningful conversations.
And then we talk about what we've seen.
When we look at the core values,
a lot of what we saw was
evidence of others first.
Just how they responded to each other
was a sure example of that.
So having that conversation
is really helpful,
because we get a lot of feed back.
- You watched hands go like this.
- But as they were talking to each other
you see some of the
hands kind of slide down.
- They feel like there
should be a right or a wrong,
but you're trying to get them
to see their own identity,
and I think that that's
where you're pushing them.
- When I get feedback
from my colleagues, like,
"hey immediately you
had three or four table
groups that raises their hand,"
I now am more aware
going into another class
am I answering that question,
or am I posing another question
that allows the student to dig deeper.
You guys are working,
you've got 15 to 20 minutes.
- We've seen just huge
reductions in off task behaviors
- What about rays?
- [Jessica] I think one
of the biggest benefits
to the consistency is
there's a common language,
when a kid hears me say,
"good job, you really showed grit there
and persevered through it."
And they go to another classroom
and they hear the same
thing, there's no confusion.
We are able to instill in
them a changed perspective.
It allows us to access the resources
that are already in them, going,
"hey you have this great
capacity to learn, and grow."
- I'm not going to say
it defines who I am,
but to the world, yes.